Oh
so I'm not going to lie one of the few
Disney sequels that piqued my interest a
little bit was Little Mermaid - a sigh
of return too far I never saw any of the
Disney sequels they just didn't peak my
interest and I think I was a little too
old for him but when I saw the
commercials for this one about Ariel's
daughter who's a human who wants to
become a mermaid I thought that's kind
of a clever idea okay I wasn't expecting
much I know it's a Disney sequel but I
thought there were thin possibilities in
this I popped it in give it a watch and
yeah it sucked okay maybe that too
strong a word but it just felt like an
hour and a half of nothing this story
should be so easy to make interesting
but instead you just felt like they're
going through the motions the motions
that we got see these characters again
we got do at least five dumb kids movies
cliches that you've seen everywhere and
we have to in no way make the characters
feel like their decisions are making the
story flow doing what the story says
they have to do that's a shame because
like I said I thought this was a good
idea Aereo and Erik have given birth to
a little girl named melody she's about
to be introduced to her grandfather
Triton but then her solos crazy sister
interrupts and threatens to kill melody
and let's try it in hands over his magic
trynna she's defeated but they decided
to follow frozen parents logic and just
keep her away from the thing that she
would obviously be very drawn to instead
of finding about a million other ways
around this so she can never be told
about merpeople or the sea or anything
like that in fact they even built a wall
in between the kingdoms insert some joke
here let's write and tell Sebastian to
keep an eye on her because yeah that
makes sense and twelve years passed but
everybody acts like it was just 12
minutes no really
12 years later Sebastian is like oh look
after her he said but wait why are you
acting like he just said that was 12
years ago
also Ursula sister is trying to turn
this little guppy back into a shark that
was just transformed into a guppy why
are you still doing this 12 years later
and acting like it just happened a few
minutes ago
the kind of logic this movie runs on
melody constantly sneaks under the wall
and goes into the sea because she loves
it so much she doesn't question that she
can talk to crabs and fish and seagulls
but apparently everyone else does and
sees her as kind of weird when Sebastian
accidentally gets loose during a party
and causes a big scene
she thinks she's to blame even though
nobody says she's to blame and this
ruins her big night that I guess could
have possibly gone awkward anyway you
see Ariel cross her fingers that we
don't know why she's afraid to dance
with his boy though we don't know why
she looks down at her feet like she
doesn't know how to dance but this was
never addressed yeah we're not even at
the meet of the story yet and nothing is
adding up she finds her own magical
locket that shows that the underwater
city is real and this convinces her that
it's totally rational to leave her home
and try to find it yeah again kind of
crazy she comes across earth Allah
sister who turns her into a mermaid but
family says she doesn't have enough
magic to keep her that way the only
thing that does have enough magic is
King Triton's trident who she now says
he stole from her because melody has
become too stupidly written kid syndrome
like it all bad scripts she believes her
thinks tried to news the bad guy and
goes and tries to steal from along the
way she comes across see Timon and
Pumbaa yeah I'm sure they have other
names but it's just Timon and Pumbaa
underwater and she even totally 100%
betrays her mother while also
simultaneously dooming the world a whole
God is this movie stupid every second
there's another dumb thing that doesn't
add up or something that just makes a
character look selfish or idiotic when
Elodie finds out that her mother has
been lying to her and that her life is a
lie
look at it she runs right past her dad
but dad doesn't even give a oh hey
real what's up
why care daughter you idiot he doesn't
even go with Ariel to go find her he
just stays behind and says good luck
even Jasmine threw a punch in aladdin 3
this guy just does nothing the only
character is very occasionally of
interest are either melody or the evil
sister once in a while they do a good
expression on them
hey pet Carroll's back to do the voice
you can read the phonebook and make it
sound deliciously evil even the
animation is just generic I can't say
it's bad but nothing really stands out
about it either
I remember the incredible expressions
that they gave Ariel in the first one
even when she couldn't talk the
animation on her face was just so
passionate and so well done here she
just feels like a robot look kind of
happy look kind of sad look kind of
worried look kind of whimsical
it's like talking the notes instead of
singing those the Disney sequels ahead
generic animation always had something
that stood out about it Pocahontas too
had a lot of great expressions and some
good nature shots Beauty and the Beast
too has a nice winter color than that
awesome organ this just seems like it's
there to do its job and that's it I
can't totally blame them I'm sure they
were rushed and had to get it out fast
but it's just so weird that nothing
freaking nothing stands out about it
even the songs are forgettable I don't
remember a single one I don't know I
guess I shouldn't be shocked I mean it's
a Disney sequel this is what we're
supposed to expect but I really like
this idea I wanted to see more of melody
longing for the sea I wanted to see more
conflict between her and the parents I
wanted her when she finally gets into
the ocean to see what a spectacular
world it is like her life is starting
anew but instead of feeling any of that
you're just kind of shown it you're told
what's going on and not experiencing it
I guess it's not awful especially
compared to other Disney sequels it's
just bland and not very memorable and
for an idea like this especially being a
sequel to such a passionate film you
would think even a rushed sequel off of
something so passionate would be some
kind of impact I guess it's fine and
corny enough for little kids but for
someone who really loved the Beauty
energy and elegance of the original for
me
this definitely flounders
you